[Music]
today's question comes from jimmy in
kentucky my wife and i are on baby step
three and would love to buy a home but
we're nowhere near able to put down
money on a house we are concerned that
the market will continue to increase
before we can get a down payment saved
up can we use my va loan to take
advantage of the zero percent payment
down payment
to get into a house sooner and refinance
in three to five years
jimmy
i'm gonna say no
[Laughter]
i mean va loans they're just it's just
not it's not a great option i mean
there's so much with the fees everything
that that that is in that
uh it makes it a difficult it's a
difficult mortgage and
between fha va and conventional it's the
most expensive
unless you are disabled if you're a
fully disabled veteran then they waive a
lot of the fees and stuff but it is not
it's not a good deal for you and
basically what you're doing is you're
trying to find a way to game the system
you know you want to scan the system and
the system isn't broke and it means
delayed pleasure and yes house prices
are going to continue to go up they're
not going to continue to go up like they
have been
the market has slowed down substantially
uh we anticipate real estate prices in
the year
2022 to go up about seven percent
next year 23 which is when you would be
buying a house or 24. they're going
gonna go up four to five percent a year
that is not going to price you out of
the market jimmy
what will price you out of the market is
doing it dumb
and moving into something when you're
broke and you have no down payment and
you're not ready to buy you're going to
get in a problem
you're you know that they they're
you know you're going to create friction
here in your life it's not going to be
fun and you're going to turn we want you
to have a house we don't want the house
to have you yeah and that's what ends up
happening so much we talked about on the
show yesterday with george that you know
your home it's such an emotional thing
right it's like where your family is
it's where you sleep at night it's where
you do your meals i mean like it is it's
such an emotional part of your life
and so many people rush into that so
it's an emotional part of your life and
it's the most expensive part of your
life it's usually the largest purchase
you ever make
and so because of that it's like you
people make
not wise decisions when it comes to
their money with their houses because
they just let their emotions get ahead
of them whether it's fear whether it's
longing for something there's all these
stupid people that are around you
telling you all the time to buy
something you got to buy a house you got
to buy house you got a buy house you got
a bus you can be a renter you got to buy
a house everybody oh god oh god oh god
you're going to get priced out okay okay
and you know what is your beautician and
economist
the lady doing your nails is not an
economist oh my god you know so stop
listening to these broke people with
their
craziness uh because i've heard that for
30 years yeah for 30 years i've heard
i'm going to get priced out of the
market and i can tell you real estate's
considerably more expensive than when i
started this show 30 years ago
but but you know and it'll be more
expensive 30 years from now when you're
still doing the show so but the uh uh
god will and the creek don't rise but oh
my gosh
the uh uh
that's but there's a lot of outside
pressure family members and everybody
else oh you haven't bought a house yet
but you've been married 26 seconds and
you hadn't bought a house oh my god and
there's all this craziness out there
well that and then on top of all the
emotion of just the recent yeah real
estate i mean all of it right so it's
it's
i don't know there's a lot 2020 was one
of the highest increases in house prices
in history yeah of all time i mean in
modern history
and 29
it went up oh my that's unbelievable
unprecedented as they say in the covet
language
but yeah oh my gosh
yeah that's just crazy and so uh it
scares the crud out of you but it's not
it's not that's not going to be
what happens going forward it's also not
going to crash for those of you waiting
on the prices to go down well let me
let's talk about this because i've been
there's there's been so much i feel like
even in the recent probably like week or
two about the real estate market because
there's i read an article this morning
the seven cities where it continues to
increase substantially right so there
was so i read that and then there are
places though that they're seeing you're
seeing prices go down go down
and so
the important thing there is to remember
that that's still buyers i'm sorry
sellers
some of them are still in the mindset of
oh i can make yeah so much they're still
looking for a sucker coming from another
city so when you're seeing those prices
i just want to know your thoughts on it
is it going back to just true home value
of what the what the house is really
worth
versus the inflated prices
and so when
when do you know what your house is
valued at like a true value after all
the craziness of it going up so fast
is it that you can can you still run
copies like you know what i mean it's
going up so fast as a reality okay so
the definition
of
market value for real estate yep when i
was in appraisal class yep a thousand
years ago is still in college it's still
the definition and every real estate
test you ever take to get your real
estate license is when a willing buyer
meets a willing seller and neither are
under duress
okay
webster
so you have a buyer and a seller and
neither one of them are freaking out
okay okay the seller is not motivated by
a divorce or a bankruptcy or something
else okay okay the buyer is not over
motivated because the last three houses
they put offers in they didn't get and
so the marketplace is so white hot that
the buyer is under duress and so some of
these buyers were paying above market
value but their purchase does not enter
into an appraisal
that that property is not an actual
indicator of value okay because the one
of the parties was under duress yes you
can't use okay a foreclosure on your
street does not affect the value of your
house because one of the parties was
under duress okay so that's not a value
how are you so how people out there that
are wanting
to buy yourself like how do you run
comps now because i'm like usually you
just run comps something like that you
run comps and if one of them sticks up
and shows all are gonna stick up right
maybe maybe i mean if you if everybody
was a white hot buyer in the whole area
then the value probably has gone up yeah
because the marketplace was in the rest
right
but if you've got some one-offs like you
know we we talked about during the thing
i live in a neighborhood where like
like almost all the houses that sold in
it's a nice neighborhood uh sold
recently where california people moving
in with california equity
and the tennessee people are sitting
there going
i got a sucker on the hook here yeah
they're gonna way overpay because they
can't get a house there's a shortage and
so they're gonna they're overpaying
substantially
over value and and so enough of that
happens then other people get greedy and
they're like oh i didn't really want to
sell my house but if i could sell it for
that i'd sell it yeah what the heck and
yeah and one of the guys i was playing
golf with we talked about that during
the streaming thing that we're doing he
goes i put mine on the market i put an
extra 200 000 bucks on it looking for
one of those california sucker fish i'm
gonna hook me one you know and it didn't
sell
yeah and he said i haven't been able to
hook one so the market has calmed down
the market has calmed down and the
migration from california or new york or
wherever into these
other uh markets you know yeah the
southeastern markets primarily is slowed
down yep but we've had a million plus
people displaced from just california
and new york yep just those two states
moved out
into other markets and that
it adversely affects what is a real
value yes real value should be based on
a calm reasonable wise transaction by
both parties yes and even that goes up
three to five percent a year yep yep
it's good